well omicron is spreading in israel the
country of over 9 million people has
seen infection rates skyrocket in the
past week with prime minister nathalie
bennett warning that up to 4 million
people could be infected the fast
spreading variant has prompted worries
that the government is no longer on top
of the pandemic dw's tanya kramer
reports now from tel aviv
the line is long for a free covet 19
anti-gen test at this official center in
tel aviv
with the omigron variant spreading fast
free pcr tests are now reserved for
people over 60 and other high-risk
groups
everybody else is required to take an
antigen test first with ever-changing
rules patience is running low basically
the rules change on a daily basis there
is a joke that if you refresh the news
the news page then you get different
restrictions and different
rules
it feels like a circus if they cancel
the pcr tests then they should let us do
the antigen testing at home and send our
kids back to school
now we have to stand here can't work and
just
israel had made an early bet on its
rapid vaccination campaign in october it
had successfully slowed down the delta
wave by administering a third booster
shot but now the country struggles with
the omegran variant
we're talking a variant that is
spreading very fast the incubation
period is about two days not seven days
as used to be
so this is why many of the
epidemiological measures uh especially
testing and breaking chain of
transmission are much less
efficient
right now
much of israel's covet strategy had been
focused on vaccination over 4.3 million
israelis have taken the third booster
shot less than half of the population of
roughly 9.4 million
since last week the country has begun to
roll out the fourth boost for people
over 60 medical staff and other
high-risk groups
okay
each time
we boost
we fortify our immune response we deepen
the immune memory and enhance our
ability to cope more efficiently with
the variants that are already
challenging us and those that will and
unfortunately will emerge
but it is still unclear how hospitals
will cope during this fifth wave
at irelov hospital in tel aviv family dr
laura azuri takes us to the covet 19
ward
not every bed is occupied right now but
numbers of severely ill patients are
increasing daily
a majority are unvaccinated or have
underlying health conditions
at the moment some of our patients are
vaccinated some are not
everyone hospitalized has underlying
health conditions hard kidney condition
or diabetes but again the vaccinations
are very important
[Music]
after so many waves of this disease
there's a sense of experienced routine
on this ward and now newly authorized
drugs can be given to patients early on
still after two years it's not just hard
for doctors and nurses to keep up but
for everyone struggling with a new
uncertainty that's replicating along
with this latest variant
and we can speak now with professor
nadav david
davidovich whom we met in that report
he's the director of the school of
public health at the faculty of health
sciences at ben gurion university and
also an advisor to the israeli
government thanks for being with us
professor how worried are you about the
current spike of infections in israel
we are indeed an unprecedented times
although the omicron is probably
less severe from a clinical perspective
the huge wave the
pace of transmission
and the combination of
influenza that is very
uh prevalent now in israel as in other
countries including severe cases all
these create a huge pressure on the
healthcare system
so we are going to face in the next few
weeks very challenging times we have
overwhelmed healthcare workers that we
need to take care of them
and the whole uh situation uh demand
that we are going to answer with a
multi-layer approach uh of course we are
vaccinating but vaccinations are going
to influence
um you know only later those who are not
vaccinated so we need to have also an
economic support
and to support of course the healthcare
system as well including
the burnout and the emotional aspects
for those who are really under trauma
for after two years of
a pandemia
israel has started giving people their
fourth covert jab you were talking about
vaccinations there are are vaccines
enough to stop the current wave and how
effective is a second booster against
the omicron variant
vaccinations are crucial but are not
enough uh we need to use wisely
uh the testing system for example to see
who are the high risk and
use the drugs that are now available of
pfizer in the merc
we need to have the personal
responsibility of people using masks
preventing large gatherings
and of course giving the economic
support for those who are now under
isolation so the approach is helping all
policies we cannot just rely on
vaccination there are many many other
aspects
and
we need to prioritize because the wave
is so
uh widespread uh so it's mainly about
those who are in high risk at special
programs such as protecting those in
home care facilities of course
protecting healthcare workers and other
emergency workers
and this is uh the right
approach because vaccinations are
important but they cannot solve all the
other different problems especially now
that we are in the middle of the crisis
now israel was seen as a leader in
fighting covert especially at the
beginning of the pandemic do you see it
that way now
there are many aspects that we indeed
the world leaders uh it's not just
vaccination it's the whole
epidemiological picture because we have
a amazing
health fans that are doing surveillance
so in terms of getting the
epidemiological
picture in terms of testing per capita
uh we excel in including also
vaccination there are other things that
unfortunately i'm not so proud uh the
whole school system
uh we could be much more prepared uh
reducing number of children in class
okay um so i think it's a very mixed
picture and i don't think there is any
country that is uh
uh perfect
what we're really doing very well is
uh the community healthcare system that
is preventing many hospitalization and
this is the main reason why
our death ratio is lower than most of
the countries okay professor thank you
very much that was professor nadav
davidovich director of the school of
public health at the faculty of health
sciences at ben-gurion university
you